j'accueille maintenant stéphane guillon
messieurs
bonsoir
à vous mme stéphane guillon pour la
semaine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors alors une fois n'est pas coutume
thierry je voudrais rendre hommage à la
clairvoyance de nicolas sarkozy qui
avait qualifié il y a quelques semaines
ppda et arlette chabot de trop datés
trop mou trop vu et bien j'ai bien
regardé il a raison
[Applaudissements]
municipale vikash dhorasoo s'engage aux
côtés de bertrand delanoë attention si
un ancien du psg veut vous aider à
gagner quelque chose
méfiance méfiance
delanoë rêvent-ils d'être première dame
de france un mimétisme avec carla bruni
qui laisse perplexe
et urbanisme 300 millions d'euros pour
le lifting d'une tour à la défense le
record de régine est battu
la chanteuse qui perd deux records cette
semaine puisque ségolène royal a déclaré
51 mille euros de frais de maquillage
pour sa campagne
société après la disparition de louis
cazenave il ne reste plus qu'un seul
poilus protestations de demis roussos de
dettes contre du loup
[Musique]
droit d'inventaire en mai 68 michel
drucker aurait crié crs ss et jeté des
pavés si vous possédez un cliché de
michel jetant un pavé écrivez nous ça
nous intéresse
la garde-robe de mitterrand aux enchères
non celle de sarkozy est invendable
peut-être pour une soirée déguisée
encore
[Applaudissements]
krach boursier titre libé faut rien
exagérer les bourses mondiales se
redressent toujours exceptée celle
d'orlando là y'a rien à faire
[Applaudissements]
j'arrange pas mes affaires mais je peux
pas m'empêcher les messieurs c'est
gratuit copé est l'homme à 10 mhz ouais
enfin bon c'est mieux tu travailles
comme ça
sport pour s'entraîner les sauteurs à
skis finlandais se font propulsé dans
les airs par un partenaire la technique
la technique du lancer ça m'étonne que
brice hortefeux y ait pas pensé pour
envoyer les sans-papiers
[Applaudissements]
aller
théâtre dans le spectacle de jérôme
savary arielle dombasle est habillé en
lapin même si t'es pas du tout chasseur
ça démange
recall à propos de cécilia le magazine
gala titre et si elle était la nouvelle
diana c'est possible il faut juste
dégager le pont de l'alma dhr et un
chauffeur bourré et louer une fiat uno
voilà
[Applaudissements]
et ofas on récompense le prix du plus
gros fail on revient à julien clerc qui
a demandé à carla bruni de lui écrire
ses chansons
julien clerc mitterrandiste sous
mitterrand villepiniste souville pas
sarkozyste
et on termine par un fait divers
particulièrement triste m'est arrivé
souvent de plaisanter sur un crash
d'avion une vieille qui se fait trucider
où un bébé congelé mais aujourd'hui je
voudrais vous alerter sur le cas de
nicole borgnon
excusez moi qui a glissé sur une frite
dans un fast food et qui s'est cassé la
jambe voilà parfois s'il vous plaît
parfois l'émotion nous submerge à la
semaine prochaine merci merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux